hey babe how are you
you play really well and i'm like why
are you surprised i'm creepy too because
they'll try and ask you out through a
video game and that's yeah not
good
we're about to play never have i ever
gamer edition have you ever
never
i have like at least like by my mom
beauty games are for lazy people who
don't do real things
of course
[Laughter]
i have been told that i shouldn't play
video games by people online while i was
playing a video game
it was in overwatch and they said that i
was a horrible uh tank and that i should
go do something really bad to myself
i actually won a super smash brothers
tournament
and i was the only female competitor and
i bought the playstation 3 back then
with the winning funds 100
all the time yeah every day a lot of men
are bad at video games
[Music]
i've had friends though who have been
accused of cheating or like using
bots or something and i'm like no
they're actually just really kick-ass
ladies
doing amazing things in video games so
i've seen it for sure they see a woman
they get scared
i don't play with people that like suck
i play a lot of dna i've been accused of
like by like old dms i've played with
being like wait what like what are your
spells wait no there's no way that you
like were able to do that yeah roll it
again roll it again or and i'm like no
this is like the mechanic what are you
talking about
oh i've definitely been told that it was
going easy on me and i'm like
thanks
one i don't care too that's stupid yeah
i've been told that it people were going
easy on me because i was playing with
them or they were trying to help me
and like carry me another thing is that
they said oh i was trying to help help
carry you through this game so it kind
of
same same vein the fun thing though is
then when you're like okay let's do a
rematch and then you win again
and they're like i still wasn't ready
[Music]
i haven't but i don't like do stuff
online yeah
i have but
in all honesty i get more flirtatious
dms yeah then it's kind of like a it's
kind of a
hybrid bag i definitely receive those
regularly and i know people try to send
them to me regularly after i beat them
in a game like fortnight i'll get friend
requests from people and i don't answer
them because i know they're just going
to try to flame me and that is sort of
shitty that's awful it happens a lot so
i just avoid it
[Music]
i choose to ignore the toxicity and i
will carry on playing i get affected
i've had i have to step away sometimes
depending on the game depending on the
comments it absolutely messes with your
mental mm-hmm
i play fortnite squads with with a bunch
of girls with like a whole squad of
girls why haven't we not been friends
before can i fix that like tonight yeah
let's go
i'm like
excuse me i would say yeah usually
there's like one other something i've
done with like one other girl but then
the rest of the group is guys really
yeah but not like an all girl group that
was probably one of the best times i've
ever had in my life yeah my guild right
now is like 50 women maybe a little bit
more and it's the first time i've ever
played in a guild that had
more than one woman
ready player one yeah also ready player
one
yeah
what's that one with um ryan reynolds
free guy oh free guy
haven't seen it we'd love to see it yeah
does a movie with gaming gamers
that are women exist do women exist do
women exist i don't know
do i exist i need to see a movie with
women gamers yes one up is coming on
july 15th only on prime video we're
gonna start an all girls team and take
down
[Music]
you